one of the major Revelations of the
Trump tax returns has nothing to do with
Donald Trump it actually has to do with
the IRS and there's a really good
article in The Daily Beast by Sean Wu
called we haven't seen Trump's taxes yet
but it's clear the IRS failed America
the IRS is required to conduct audits of
the President and Vice President while
they're in office but Trump apparently
got a pass we'll link to this article in
the description for the YouTube video
that we're going to put up but let's
talk about the big picture here
the IRS didn't even audit the president
who's supposed to be audited as a matter
of of automatic principle it's supposed
to be mandatory audit of the president
and as you zoom out you find yet another
one of these projection
hypocrisy logic pretzels that the right
often gets itself into
they complain about the IRS the IRS is
too big
and the IRS is cracking down too much on
the wealthy and the IRS is politically
biased and going after the conservatives
even though we know that that's actually
that that was an Obama era pseudo
Scandal which has been completely
debunked and they say were for Law and
Order
and yet what we see is they never want
to fully fund the IRS and they seem
perfectly happier at least indifferent
to the fact that the IRS isn't even
really doing the minimum it's almost
like they don't really want rich people
and in particular Rich conservatives to
have to follow the rules
predating this specific incident think
back
the IRS has a history of discrimination
and unequal enforcement especially
against marginalized communities and
small business owners we could also look
at the ongoing issues with the irs's
outdated and error-prone systems which
for average taxpayers just make it
really difficult to get your taxes done
people often end up going to paid
Services even though there are often
free services available depending on
your income the confusion and the
frustration that the IRS continues to
put taxpayers through average taxpayers
combined with the tax software Lobby
which is very strong create a situation
where for many of the average taxpayers
with average incomes it's both more
expensive and more complicated and
frustrating and convoluted to file our
taxes than it has to be while meanwhile
the very rich and the privileged take
advantage of all sorts of different
mechanisms to often end up paying a
dramatically lower effective tax rate
than people with significantly lower
incomes that's a failure of the IRS and
of the elected officials that dictate
tax policy and manage the IRS and then
when you think about what is this really
done
the IRS has played a major role in
enabling corruption and abuses of Power
by the wealthy and Powerful by turning a
blind eye to what is and again we tax
avoidance and evasion of I believe
avoidance is legal whereas evasion is
not there's a gray area there in terms
of the spirit of of a lot of these laws
if not the letter by turning apply a
blind eye to it and failing to even
adequately audit and investigate
high-income people in corporations they
are allowing the wealthy to buy their
way out of paying their fair share above
and beyond what the tax code is even
trying to achieve so this is the type of
stuff that erodes trust and faith in
government and meanwhile they want to
tell you oh Biden wants to double the
size of the IRS and arm everyone when
the truth is that there's 55 000 IRS
people expected to retire over the next
10 years 55 000 of the new hires are
just to replace people that are retiring
that just gets us to where we are now in
terms of their arming the IRS the IRS
has a small law enforcement division so
does Amtrak so does the MTA in New York
City it's not really a big deal it's not
actually an authoritarian police state
Crackdown they want to focus on that
when the truth is the IRS is
dramatically undersized and underpowered
and that's really what we're learning
from the Trump tax return story
good habits have to be sustainable in
order to become habits it has to be
something you'll actually do and when it
comes to nutrition some people have
hours to plan out every meal their exact
vitamin intake I'm not doing any of that
I don't have the time here's what's
sustainable for me I start my day with
just a single scoop of ag-1 from
athletic greens it gives me the entire
day's worth of the 75 high quality
vitamins minerals and probiotics I want
from whole food sources it's just simple
it's just one scoop of ag1 I get all the
nutrients I want I don't have to do any
math use my protractor my TI-83 or take
a bunch of different capsules and pills
it's not some kind of wacky supplement
making a bunch of crazy claims you know
I would not promote something like that
ag1 is just a simple product it does
what it says it does it gives you the
daily nutrients and vitamins you likely
want vitamin A C E magnesium zinc
potassium in one simple scoop you keep
your body nourished you'll also get a
free year supply of vitamin D which I
take in the winter plus five free travel
packs at athleticgreens.com Pacman the
link is down below